vous ne pourra jamais être vraiment
prêts à affronter une catastrophe
naturelle de l'ampleur de celle qui
affligent la colombie britannique
une fois tous les 100 ans du temps et
encore mais avec les changements
climatiques il faut s'attendre à ce
qu'elles soient de plus en plus
fréquentes extrême imprévisible le
canada doit faire face un peu partout à
des feux de forêt ici on a connu une
fameuse tempête de verglas mais le
risque qu'ils dominent généralement
c'est ce qu'on voit dans l'ouest et
qu'on a vu en 1996 au saguenay les
inondations c'est beaucoup les
inondations ont pu même au niveau
national aussi c'est à peu près trois
corps des trois quarts des financements
après une après les désastres en en
fédérale 3 encore de l'argent
le gouvernement fédéral a confié à
l'institut canadien pour des choix
climatique le soin de recenser les
risques accrus pour les infrastructures
et les citoyens qui vivent en fonction
du réchauffement de la planète une fois
passé l'urgence en colombie britannique
il recommande le diagnostic en mettant à
jour la cartographie des risques mais je
pense qu'à plus long terme quand je
mentionnais ce qui est important c'est
vraiment d'avoir l'information au canada
en ce moment les cartes de plaine
inondable sont désuètes et datent des
années 70 80 en moyenne et puis font
certainement pas référence aux
changements climatiques donc à ce à quoi
on peut s'attendre donc ça je pense que
c'est la première chose à faire au
niveau du gouvernement fédéral cessé de
travailler je sais que le travail est en
train de faire en ce moment
pour que cette information ne soit
disponible qu'il soit utile pour pour la
prise de décision une cartographie c'est
ce qu'a fait la communauté
métropolitaine de montréal après les
inondations catastrophiques de 2017 sur
les rives du lac des deux montagnes nos
cartes datait des années soixante dix
elles étaient faites différemment d'une
ville autre on n'avait pas la même
méthodologie et on a convenu
collectivement qu'on devait se doter
d'un plan archipel inondations donc il y
aura un angelot majeurs sont vus bien
géré un territoire faut bien connaître
qui vient de connaître ça passe par des
bonnes cartes pour ce faire il faut lui
faire un relevé qu'on appelle le relever
lit dans le relevé l'idée c'est un
faisceau laser qui lui vaut ce canal
territoire au complet et va nous donner
exactement la topographie ou satimat
green résultats en 2019 la ville de
montagne durement touché deux ans plus
tôt restent les pieds au sec parce
qu'elle participe au projet pilote de la
cmm alors que sa voisine sainte marthe
sur le lac est aux prises avec la même
catastrophe qu'en 2017 c'est un cocktail
de mesures qui est proposé on comprend
la wii à la digue we watched were oui
d'autres mesures qui vont nous permettre
de capter l'eau de la stocker d'évacuer
c'est ce qui fait que c'est un projet
résilient fin 2021 sainte marthe sur le
lac elle aussi est protégée par de
nouvelles digues réhaussé comme ses
voisines un projet modèle je pense que
oui au niveau local jusqu'à d'autres
municipalités aussi au canada qui sont
qu'ils ont fait la même chose qu'ils ont
créé leur propre carte de l'inondation
j'étais content d'entendre aussi que
c'est que ces projeter dans le futur le
selon les selon les changements
climatiques puisque ça va emmener mais
c'est certainement le point de départ
pour justement faire la prise de
décision le prendrais prendre les bonnes
décisions comme ont mentionné les
municipalités sont responsables
d'environ 60% des infrastructures au
canada mais ils ont pas nécessairement
les fonds pour pouvoir réagir non reste
les routes les ponts les voies de chemin
de fer tous les secteurs de la société
et les gouvernements doivent revoir
leurs projets et investir lourdement bon
alors c'est clair c'est des milliards de
dollars le 6 si les gouvernement
s'active à
élaborer des politiques pour pour déjà
de donner l'information savoir où le
risque se trouve par rapport aux
inondations surtout par rapport à créer
les infrastructures qui sont qui sont à
risque
on peut ça va coûter très cher
la sortie de coville est un bon moment
pour investir en relançant l'économie et
en sachant que réparer les pots cassés
après le désastre coûtera toujours plus
cher sainte-marthe-sur-le-lac en porte
encore les cicatrices tout en subissant
les foudres de ceux qui ont perdu leur
vue sur le lac à cause de la digue mais
c'est au nom du bien commun